now to the impact of canada's busiest
border crossing a peaceful protest is
legal in canada blocking highways in the
u.s canada border for days and
restricting the rights and freedoms of
others is not the protest on the
ambassador bridge from windsor to
detroit has cut supply lines and is now
costing jobs sean o'shea is in windsor
for us again tonight sean
donna four days into this bridge
blockade both countries are starting to
see the economic impacts especially the
auto manufacturing sector
protesters refuse to budge and take
pride in the pain they're inflicting we
are costing the mayor doug ford all the
people a lot of money this group is
still camped on the canadian side of the
ambassador bridge linking windsor to
detroit on a normal day 450 million
dollars worth of goods crosses here with
a bridge link fully closed manufacturers
are losing business and their employees
are losing work the potential for
more layoffs and re
additional reduced hours is just going
to increase ford temporarily shut down
its engine plant here and cut a shift
from its assembly plant in oakville
stelantis formerly fiat chrysler
shortened shifts at several plants and
toyota said it would not manufacture
anything at three canadian plants for
the rest of the week the law needs to be
enforced this is too important of a
piece of infrastructure for the canadian
economy and this is now hurting canadian
jobs
the frustration attracting more american
media by the day when a fox news crew
showed up they were welcomed
enthusiastically by the crowd
contrast that with what outlets like
global news are experiencing over the
past day the first signs of police
tactical units have shown up ontario
provincial police have arrived too and
concrete barriers are being set up
designed to prevent more vehicles from
joining the blockade they need to step
up because clearly whatever they've been
doing
to this point hasn't been working more
here justify their actions even while
acknowledging their own neighbors will
be financially hurt by this shutdown
we're not the ones stopping this economy
trudeau has halted this economy long
before we're here that's why we're here
as for how long this protest could go on
that's anybody's guess but the governor
of michigan gretchen whitmer asked
canadian authorities today to do
something about it right now in her
words it's simple it's time to reopen
traffic on the bridge
donna
all right sean o'shea in windsor ontario
thank you